the one characteristic that I'm very
very comfortable saying that all of the
leaders I've met have is
courage um and you know you could rank
Integrity there but I think it takes
courage to have integrity you know to do
the right thing in the face of
overwhelming pressure to do something
different to speak truth to power you
know all those Integrity things that
takes courage it is very difficult to
lead you know I think we we we celebrate
it and but I don't think people realize
just how hard it is um the only analogy
I would offer is parenting
you know having a kid is so fun but
raising a kid is excruciating sorry did
I say that was a little too quick you
little it's really difficult and it's
often thankless and it's often lonely
and it's often exhausting and it's often
infuriating it's often frustrating and
you screw it up on a regular basis and
you're like that's it I've screwed up my
kid for life you know um and yet for
some reason it's one of the most
rewarding if not the most rewarding
thing you'll ever do in your life for
these unexpected glimmers you know when
you catch your 5-year-old sharing with
your four-year-old when you check to
make sure you're 8-year-old is sleeping
to find out that they're under the
blankets with a flashlight reading you
know um the first job the first school
play you know all of these unexpected
glimmers make all the sacrifice and
exhaustion worth it and Leadership is
the same you know leadership is lonely
very often um thankless very often
unfair like if everything goes right you
have to give we all the credit and
everything goes wrong you have to take
all the accountability well that sucks
but it is those unexpected little
glimmers like when your team rallies
around help to help each other when
someone when somebody's struggling or
when they solve an unsolvable problem
and you sit back and you be like yeah
that's my team you know and it makes it
all worth it